muy bien ya existe algunos programas te
debes estar preguntando cómo voy a
recordar todos estos comandos es un
óvalo o un círculo o una elipse es
primero el ancho y después de altura o
es al revés tengo que memorizar todo
esto por suerte no para eso sirven las
computadoras el punto es que siempre
tenemos una computadora cuando
programamos las computadoras son mejores
que nosotros recordando cosas entonces
porque no sólo dejamos que la
computadora recuerde todos los detalles
por nosotros y las amos como un
diccionario para programar entonces nos
concentramos en hacer buenos programas
sino en detalles aburridos a eso se le
llama documentación un documento que
explica cómo programar con todo ese
lenguaje y nos da ejemplos entonces si
no nos acordamos de todos los detalles
no hay problema solo los buscamos seguro
crees que es aburrido leer documentación
y tienes razón es algo aburrido es más
divertido escribir un código pero al
menos que quieras aprenderte todo de
memoria necesitas aprender a usar
documentación para poder codificar tus
ideas incluso los mejores programadores
no tratan de memorizar todo es más
algunos de los mejores programadores
también son los mejores
documentación por ejemplo estoy
dibujando esta cara sonriente y ya
dibujé la cara y los ojos usando elipses
una función que conozco bastante bien
pero tengo más trabajo que hacer primero
quiero dibujar la cara con bordes
gruesos como una calcomanía me acuerdo
que la función tiene algo que ver con
nuestro pero no me acuerdo el nombre
exacto entonces en vez de quedarme aquí
a inventar lo que me llevaría a horas o
tiempo infinito solo iré a la parte de
documentación y tratar de encontrar lo
que busco entonces miren la categoría de
colores porque me parece probable que
esté ahí miro todas las funciones y al
final encuentro la que busco la que
cambia el grosor de las líneas y los
contornos entonces aquí vemos la función
de los parámetros solo uno en este caso
lo que usualmente hago es copiar este
código y pegarlo en mi código
pero inmediatamente me aparece un error
el espesor no está definido y es que
cines no es un verdadero valor
yo quiero reemplazar eso por lo que en
realidad busca obtener eso puede ser con
un número o con un valor que se refiera
a ese número así que en este caso pondré
un número okay perfecto se ve bien 10
está bien pero podemos ajustarlo eso es
un poco extremo eso es muy pequeño muy
bien entonces regresemos 12 genial es
muy obvio que algo falta en la cara
sonriente
la sonrisa
entonces hago algo más o menos así
y puedo mirar la sonrisa y pensar bueno
eso no luce como algo que pueda dibujar
con el lips on line o recto tiene esta
curva pero no tiene algo dentro entonces
pienso debo revisar la documentación
para ver si hay otra manera de hacer una
curva como esta
entonces vamos a la documentación para
seguir nos desplazamos hacia abajo y
buscamos
voy a revisar la categoría de figuras
ajá
aquí tenemos esta función arc que se usa
para dibujar un arco
suena perfecto para dibujar la sonrisa
esta función tiene más parámetros
comenzaré pegando la función aquí y
recuerda en este lugar van los
parámetros y necesitamos reemplazarlos
ok xy tal vez aquí se indican donde
quiero comenzar entonces veamos dónde
está la mitad 100 entonces comenzaré con
150 y entonces ya es tal vez 250 luego
ancho ancho suena al ancho del arco tal
vez un poco menos que el ancho de la
cara así que tal vez sea 200 y luego
altura tal vez altura sea la medida
desde lo alto del arco hasta el fondo
así que eso podría ser 50
luego comienza y termina en realidad no
sé qué es eso bueno pues ahora estoy
atorada porque estoy viendo esta función
y quiero usarla pero en realidad no
entiendo estos parámetros bueno
afortunadamente lo que puedes hacer
simplemente es regresar a los documentos
y presionar la función que te interesa y
al hacerlo aparecerá un programa que te
mostrará cómo usarla y te explicará los
parámetros con mucho más detalle así que
al ver esto vemos que x xi es la
coordinada en x del centro de la elipse
de la que se deriva el arco bien así que
básicamente parece que para dibujar un
arco tienes que pensar qué pretendes
dibujar una elipse pero sólo una parte
de ella y calcular todo en base a eso
así que la xy la ye cambiando el centro
de la elipse que pretendemos que estamos
haciendo ancho y altura son el ancho y
lo alto de la elipse y comienza y
termina esos son los que no entendía
comienza y termina con el ángulo o bien
el ángulo de inicio el ángulo en el que
inicia el arco en grados y termina es
donde termina cierto y podemos observar
los ejemplos que han puesto aquí así que
dibujar el arco
270 eso es probablemente este de aquí
cierto porque de 1 a 170 grados debería
verse como esto vamos a tratar de
cambiarlo aquí vamos esto tiene sentido
cierto porque de 1 a 180 a algo así es
lo que queremos queremos un medio arco
bien así que ahora creo que entiendo ar
que lo suficientemente bien como para
usarla regresemos a nuestra cara
sonriente muy bien entonces vamos de 0 a
180 y casi lo logramos mi valor de x
está fuera porque no sabía que x en
realidad es el centro de la elipse
y es un poco ancho así que vamos a
hacerlo un poco más pequeña
ahora si tengo una cara sonriente de
verdad gracias al uso de la
documentación pude hacer lo que quería
mucho más rápido y ese es un objetivo
cuando se programa convertir tus ideas
en realidad más rápido recuerda usa el
poder de la documentación